okay Logan's Run yeah another forgotten
classic this is a one that I saw when I
was a little kid this is pre Star Wars
yeah it came out almost exactly a year
before Star Wars right I first came in
contact with it probably like in third
grade second grade I would hear oh the
kids talking about Logan's Run Sandman
and runners and then of course a few
months later Star Wars came out and then
everyone got that totally forgotten
that's right and I didn't see it in the
theater some of the kids this would
probably like you know from what I
understand it came out in 1976 yeah so
he's 76 yeah I understand you know some
people would probably our British
listeners would be appalled but many
people took their kids to see this one
yeah you know and well by today's
standards it wasn't that bad everyone
super-violent her yeah there was a
couple seconds that was not really that
big a deal yeah and there was people
being sacked by laser beams and being
killed off at 30
yeah true but this is one that we saw
now when after Star Wars came out they
actually played Logan's Run on
television yeah and I think California I
think that's where I ended up seeing it
I think it kind of went into rotation on
one of the pay channels so I probably
saw it in the early 80s I think I saw it
like it may be a 77 yeah cuz Star Wars
came out and Logan's Run lost its value
so they just put it on local television
yeah I felt like Logan's Run kind of
came out its kind of the same sort of
genre as you know like thx 1138 Planet
of the Apes brave new world
Soylent Green yeah like all those kind
of West world all those kind of movies
and really I feel like the late 60s
early 70s that was kind of the beginning
of sci-fi being taken a little bit more
seriously maybe I think it was still you
know by movie makers like by Hollywood
in general and still kind of considered
a quote-unquote like a ghetto genre
which I think was a holdover from the
50s and 60s with the you know like the
big bug movies and all the silly the
Logan sci-fi I do this run I think was
probably one of them really the first
really big sci-fi movies yes they spent
a lot it was MGM and they gently
nine million dollars on there was a lot
of money there have been 76 it had good
sets uh it was filmed in kind of like a
mall in Texas yeah Texas was clearly a
mall it was like a vent it was a place
where benders yeah it was like a vendor
mall like I go see other vendors layer
exam so wasn't like a publicly no no but
it's big and they had pretty good
miniatures yeah I mean obviously you can
tell they're miniatures now but you know
they look super cool you could tell
their immense respect and respect that I
maybe thought looked cool but when they
would show the pictures of Logan City
you know they had monorails and they had
buildings but there were also lakes and
and what yeah arms in it you could tell
that those that was yeah not very much
water that's kind of what gave it away
that's what gave it away the water yeah
so watch you paint a picture
tell us about Logan's Run and then what
we can make comment yeah okay so you
know maybe for younger listeners to have
a green Logan's Run but it's based on a
novel which came out seven years earlier
which was written by William F Nolan and
George Clayton Johnson it was also
called Logan's Run now the movie was a
lot different than the book and we'll
get into that a little bit later on but
the movie essentially posits the
existence of domed City a very large
dome city and I was like
post-apocalyptic apocalyptic there was a
war we [ __ ] up our environment we blew
it up guests would be a threat yes
so evidently someone at some point in
the past the movie set in 2274 at some
point the pathways that are capable to
preserve the human race they're going to
put them all inside a domed city yeah
they control their reproduction they
base it seems like they don't say this
outright but it does seem like the
babies or maybe test-tube babies or that
they don't reproduce in the normal way
right they did not really create ever
the main character's name is Logan five
and he's a Sandman who's kind of like a
cop in this situation he goes to a
nursery to see his son yeah
quote-unquote yeah he calls it his son
but they never mentioned any mother yes
so I kind of led to believe that what it
is
is that that's Logan six and then yeah
that their clothes their clothes I think
yeah I think so that's what I think the
implication is because they never show
any pregnant girls or women or any kind
of child-rearing
in fact they what's what's the female
characters dedicat Jessica
jessica says she wished she had known
her mother so that means the women don't
race yeah and Logan looks at her like
she has three heads when she says that
like why are you saying such crazy thing
right yeah so I don't think there are
mothers I think they're I think their
moms
yeah clone to come out of an artificial
womb type of thing yeah like I said they
don't really say that and and there's no
connection between parents and children
because when Logan is at the beginning
at the nursery going hey it's Logan six
or whatever like his friend is like
sorry Louis is like yeah big pickup you
know what I mean right and little
children are not being raised by anybody
they're just walking around the city
yeah yeah so the whole conceit of the
movie like I said this is there's
population control in this particular
dome they never say how many people live
there he says it's thousands so I guess
look like a few thousand and everything
is basically done for them some of them
kind of have jobs because there's
plastic surgeons and things like that
yeah but you're not really expected to
do anything super productive it doesn't
seem well no yeah they're not paying
bills right they're not paying bills
they're basically all their needs are
provided their food is provided their
home is provided you know they all live
in little apart like nice apartments and
things like that I could say it was it
was a communist utopia sorta but yeah
Marxist and not really political they
didn't have any political ID now
everything was provided for them didn't
look like they were painting bills they
lived in luxury they had everything they
lived for pleasure was very hedonistic
yeah but the cost of all this is that
you had to die at 30 right they had to
go to this ritualistic destruction or
death thing called carousel yeah and it
was like a ritual they were sent in a
circle they float up towards the ceiling
towards a white crystal and they were
zapped by lasers yeah you'd be destroyed
and people thought that this was normal
this is what he had to do now some
people would try to run from it they
would become what was called runners and
sandmen who is devil Logan 5 was born a
Sandman they had they were like the cops
they had to run these or chase these
people down and zap them with a with a
butane lighter it was a gun and it shot
flames that looked just like a butane
lighter again and an explosion would
happen and then yeah they would die and
then like a little cleanup career would
calm yeah and he was in a hovercraft
they would spray some councils on the
body and if it's dissolved dissolved
yeah so that's the basic premise of the
movie is it's kind of like a utopia but
you have to die at 30 so you had the
same amount of people being born on the
same day that people died
yeah amount of people died whenever they
whenever they had the day of carousel
like everyone would go you know like
Roman Colosseum gladiator combats have a
thing everyone would go and watch it and
they would cheer the people because and
we don't know if this was a top-down
idea or this was just an idea that
evolved that the people who were dying
yeah thought they were being renewed or
thought they were making an effort to be
renewed which I assume would be
reincarnation you're going to a higher
plane or something like that obviously
they were just killed group that we know
of there was they were trying to get
something called renewal which I guess
is reincarnation but it's implied in in
a script that not everyone is renewed
they're trying to renew yeah and it's
unclear whether or not they're told this
by their society because the society is
basically run by a supercomputer yeah
find out you don't know if the
supercomputer has told them this or this
is a mythology they have invented to
explain carousel yeah I think it was a
that they invented that it might have
been a bottom up mythology yeah like
it's almost like a religion like a
religious thing we're not really dying
we're just going to another place or
we're being reincarnated yeah and
there's something about maybe I'll
reincarnate or we should fight to renew
you know I'm going to try all I can to
renew and I think it was a bottom-up
concept I think there's watching
carousel happened because it has to buy
the ads of this society and then they're
trying to rationalize it maybe I can
reincarnate now some people have said
that there's this there's
white crystal towards the ceiling that
they're floating up towards it's pretty
cool when you see the movie
some people have hypothesized that
they're trying to touch that white
crystal like grabbing the brass ring
right merry-go-round and if they touch
that white crystal maybe they renew now
the people in the movie say have you
ever seen anyone renew and they're like
no everyone just blows up Bijlee well
now there's some deleted scenes that
explain a lot of plot holes that people
have brought up in other reviews or
retrospectives and one of the one of the
things that something caught that they
mentioned something in the dysley in the
deleted scenes called flaming out now as
they're going up towards the top of that
crystal they get zapped by lasers and
they blow up yeah and the deleted scenes
are talking about that that must be that
that is the ultimate rush yeah and blown
up yeah so even if you don't renew at
least you're blowing up and it's the
ultimate rush yeah but they kind of took
that out yeah that did I don't think
they mentioned it anywhere else but it
is mentioned in the deleted scenes yeah
which of which it seems like only the
audio mostly remains yeah I think a lot
of the band gym burned a lot of burned a
lot of their stuff when they were going
back after when there was probably a lot
of stuff that that was deleted out of
the movie that explains certain things
that appear to be plot holes yeah
because I didn't feel like I do think
they're probably still a couple puddles
now when I mean I'm seeing the movie
many times and I've read a bunch of
different things about different
interpretations I haven't read the book
but I've read various breakdowns of the
plot and also there was a short-lived TV
series that came out that explained I
think it was 1977 1978 added some more
things to the mythology that might have
explained some things in the movie too
even though I heard that the TV series
wasn't very good but neither that I
remember it vaguely as a child and it
wasn't impressed yeah I think there was
only 49 I saw Logan's Run after I saw
Star Wars and I thought Logan's Run
sucked I see in Star Wars hey what else
how's your Star Wars yeah like man what
are they talking about that sucks look
at it you know look at those clothes but
as I got older and and watched Logan's
Run again you know maybe when I
in my teens it made a lot more sense I
liked it better yeah as I got older now
I can watch it go that's pretty cool
yeah it's pretty cool well the look of
it is very cool I mean it's very 70 very
70s it's the future imagined by the 70s
which is the kind of a pitfall that a
lot of sunlight falls into which i think
is why Star Wars still resonates because
it didn't fall into that but I think a
lot of sci-fi particularly in the 60s
and 70s it still looks very 60s and 70s
it doesn't look like the theater did the
right thing with Star Wars what they did
is that Star Wars was kind of looked
very 1930s yeah in a way could kind of
look futuristic in a certain ways
yes me I think that's what you should do
if you're going to do something beachy
or you can do like The Fifth Element
where they took everything from like the
18th century and then woke up it you
know that kind of thing I think that
that'll always work out better but so
anyway so in the movie Logan's Run as
Tom mentioned before there are people
called runners and they try to escape to
a place called sanctuary run if they
want to live out their complete and
total wonder these are the seditious
rebel people yeah and where the story
really gets interesting is Logan 5 after
after taking out a runner goes back to
his pad and if they have this mechanism
that's kind of like a cross between a
dating and calling lion there it's like
tinder mixed with a Star Trek teleporter
yeah I can press a button and people can
can materialize in your room you know
seeing have sex with them yeah kind of a
good idea so you just so evidently
people would offer themselves up to go
into this thing you could be selected by
somebody else
as a sidenote everybody in this movie is
hot so you know they're all young you're
all young and they're all physically fit
and they all look pretty good so you
can't really get a bad choice yeah now
one of the things that happens when
Logan 5 goes to this little tinder
teleporter the 3d out of the first thing
that appears is a gay guy yeah but he
doesn't make a judgement on it he goes
nothing I'm looking for and then another
one she was very progressive for the
time it's like they didn't make a joke
out of it they didn't he was just like
no I kind of wanted to
go down everyone yeah and didn't he ask
Jessica to when she didn't want to have
six have sex with him didn't he say oh
well do you prefer women or are you a
lesbian or no Jenny I don't know I said
well I think he said well why did you
put yourself in the circuit yeah I think
that's what the what he said and she put
herself in the circuit because she
wanted to talk about life and stuff like
that well because a friend of hers had
died at carousel that's right she wanted
to talk about the meaning of light and
everybody's like what why I want to do
that
no she's wearing a knock which Adams out
when he meets Jessica Jessica's a
British actor actor Jenny Agutter geniag
yeah she's a hottie and who's playing
Logan five what's his name again Michael
York Michael York another real handsome
guy so they start talking about the
meaning of life and she asked him about
sanctuary if she knew about sanctuary
and she's saying a lot of stuff to this
Sandman that really could get herself
into a lot of trouble very seditious
yeah it can it's against the the mores
of the society well before it gets too
deep his buddy Sandman shows up with two
other hotties and they have some some
smoked drugs and everybody's like whee
and then Jessica I about my mouth yeah
Jessica Baptist and what the drug that
they had was that he took a ball he
threw it up towards the ceiling and it
exploded into a big pink cloud it was
like it's like one of those big bass
ball things yeah put in your bathtub
that makes sure yeah he threw that large
enough anything it exploded and a big
pink cloud came down and the girls were
jumping up when we trying to grab and
then they just saw start falling on each
other and then the scene cuts away well
that rudder that he had killed earlier
that day was also wearing a knock yeah
yeah it like in his pocket or something
and and he ends up going back to work
where the big central computer is and
really this is whenever they're dealing
with the central computer I think it's
really the best scenes in the movie the
set looks really good it looks like
something on the Death Star it's black
with a lot of chrome and there's lights
and it looks like kind of a little bit
like whoever made that that set may have
had something to do with making the set
for Star Wars in the desc kind of bends
I think those were all British or
there's a lot of British people in
working on it yeah carry on movie
that looks like the Death Star Connor
well he drops a bunch of items in a
scanner from the day before to show it
to the main computer and it identifies
the awk and and he gets into this
conversation with the main computer and
the main computer is actually kind of
creepy because when you watch it there's
little pauses and it sounds it's a
woman's voice and it sounds kind of
mechanical kind of gives you the
sensation that the computer is trying to
figure out what sanctuary is emit
thinking what it does I don't know if we
mentioned it they're born with these
things in the palms or their implant
that after they're born what are the
other well they get bigger because the
little baby has running it was little
yeah it's really gross maybe it's like
an organic like a biomechanical right
it's like a little crystal a flexible
crystal in the palms of your hands it
changes color as they age yeah and when
they when it get when they get towards
last day which is you know when they
turn their either nature and 30 it turns
red and start to blink yeah and if they
pass last last day it's just black yeah
the computer asked him if he recognized
the symbol of the Ark and he's like no
and then the computer says ah kid the
Ark is talking about sanctuary what it
does is I don't want to spoil the whole
scene but I don't really remember
exactly everything that it told him it
caused his life clock to go blinking red
it took four years of his life away and
turned him into a runner to try to find
sanctuary where 1000 people were were
missing unaccounted unaccounted the
society in the society to find this
place and destroy them now he asked he
says I'm going to get my four years back
and a computer doesn't answer so he ends
up going on a run and the first person
he goes to was the was Jessica who they
do because she was also wearing an
option he was working on you must know
we must know where same areas it's kind
of interesting this part of the movie
because we assume that Logan had been
ant asking questions and he was a little
too thoughtful for a Sandman if you ask
me yeah even though he did enjoy his job
at the year look like he did enjoy
killing people I'm assuming or inferring
that that come
pewter listens to you kind of like your
smart tv listens to you yeah and and
that the computer figured this guy asked
too many questions and he knows too much
and he came in contact with a girl who
had asked him questions about sanctuary
so let's go ahead and make Logan a
runner I don't think that that computer
had any intention attention of given him
his four years back no I don't think so
it was just going to kill him
yeah so he goes on front you can go you
can take it from there Jim
he's sent out on a run almost it's
almost like the the computer setting
about an undercover mission but like you
said I don't think the computer had any
intention of letting him come back or
you know giving it was four years back
something like that now the thing we
thought was weird about this is that now
did the computer specifically tell him
not to tell the other Sandman no man
this is this is a plot hole but it may
be explained later on because of the
book maybe they were yes maybe they were
referring back to the book we're not
sure here is the weird thing Logan's
Logan's life clock goes red he runs all
right but he doesn't tell his best
friend Francis Francis who's another
Sandman he doesn't tell him that he's on
a secret mission to find sanctuary so
Francis goes after him Francis goes
after him and here's another thing
Francis knew how old he was
you would think and he would have known
that he had four years left so he should
why is he running early yeah now there's
a note there's another scene that shows
up later he and Jessica basically go to
the ghetto the ghettos where a bunch of
little kids yeah it's called Cathedral
or Cathedral and they inhale this drug
that was that was in the deleted idiot
was deleted out of the movie it was
called muscle yeah and it is accelerated
your your nervous system yet so you can
move a blinding speed it also made you
strong while they were down there
dealing with these kids he runs across
another runner who says no I'm green I'm
not a runner in other words her wife
clock had also been accelerated
she claims but she looks older anyway
yeah that he killed her yeah that's kind
of another thing that's because a lot of
the actors that are in this movie even
though they're all supposed to be under
30 some of them are clearly well over 30
yeah which
may be explained by the book because in
the book the city computer that's
running the society seems to be
malfunctioning right and it could be
that that woman actually was supposed to
be a green I'm saying too green because
that was a color bit Chris yeah and the
clothes they wore to because you had to
wear a particular color clothes
depending on what age bracket you were
in and in the book Frances the other sad
man actually was 42 yeah and they were
supposed to be dead at 20 in the book 21
21 at the book and he was actually 42
but she had cheated he had his face well
and it was a secret agent it was working
it was working with the other ground the
whole time right and in delivery he
wasn't and in the book he's pretending
to chase Logan yeah alright to find out
where sanctuary is but he knows the
sanctions that he knows that Logan's Run
is actually an artificial run right so
that may explain why in the movie
Francis's yeah chasing Logan you know as
if Logan is a real runner let me explain
what why Francis looks as old as he does
yeah cuz like it might just be like the
actors they cast the role it's kind of
hard to say because I mean obviously
even when jessica is talking to some of
the like underground people that know
about sanctuary you know some of those
people are clearly older than 30 yeah
and I don't know if that's just a case
of actors or if it's if they're just
kind of calling back to I kind of think
that maybe what was happening is is that
guys making the movie weren't really
sure which way they were going to play
the script yeah it had been a couple of
different scripts going on at the same
time yeah and then later it was decided
in editing that yeah a whole subplot of
Francis being a secret agent no and I
think maybe all that stuff got deleted
or abandoned during the film and that's
what I think yeah
honestly like I said I should say in the
book the age of death was 21 now but
also in the book there was a lot of
differences in the book it was like a
worldwide thing at 21 there was no
carousel in the book the usual so you
just submitted yourself to a place
called a sleep shop and they euthanize
you and you turn 21 now and this
happened all over the world like
everyone willingly did this which and a
couple things a couple analysis analyses
I was reading of it said you know that
may
book a little more unbelievable than the
movie actually because in the movie
everything happened under a single domed
city so everything was much more
controlled they said you know the reason
and the fact that you could live till
you were thirty made it a little bit
more believable too although the
director Michael Anderson said well the
only reason we raised the age to thirty
is because we didn't want to have to
hire a bunch of teenage actors because
it would have been too much of a pain in
the air and imagine this you're hiring
teenage actors right and some of them
are really young and then they have to
do the sex scenes right because there
might have a lot of eventualities and
then yeah and then they have to take all
the drugs yeah so so it would have been
like a little bit of a minefield but
they didn't really they want to do it
politically and under and under a
particular age also the union laws and
some yeah actors can't they can't work
more than four hours a day and they have
to have onset schooling and things like
that so it was just too cost-prohibitive
prohibitive on an already expensive
movie here's another strange thing -
okay so Logan is ostensibly sent on a
secret mission to find sanctuary right
his hand is made to start blinking and
he goes on a run with nun Jessica hooks
him up with all the underground people
yes and he goes and he has to start off
by getting his face changed at a UH
psychic surgeon Farrah Fawcett's there
yeah yes she's a receptionist
yeah she is she said she's in this in
his mobile yeah and she's Farrah Fawcett
pre Charlie's Angels yeah all right I
remember you know Beck's she was
considered to be like the it girl of the
seven oh yeah you look at her today and
she's okay looking but I think Jessica's
better looking I did too actually was a
good-looking woman but there's really
nothing special about her well me now
that's another thing that always kind of
bothered me about like Oh babes of
certain ages and stuff like that I
always wanted like why were those ones
considered pretty and other ones weren't
because to me I don't know I'm not
saying Farrah Fawcett was was a
beautiful woman but she was a very bland
boy a pretty one Jenny Agutter looked a
lot more interesting she had like a much
more like a more classically beautiful
thing yeah I thought it was just the
style as a seven I guess your house she
looks I couldn't stand that feathered
hair even by yesterday's oh my god so
there's some cool things that happen in
that and he never did does get his space
changed well because Francis figures out
that he's going to run and then follows
him to the thing that's right they have
to run out of the out of the [ __ ] and
that
Naser ends up killing the right and
there was a back door that goes into the
love shop and when they run through
there they get attacked by a slow-moving
orgy definitely saw another review of it
that's nice little potion I get attacked
by slow motion overkill I bet that's
what it looks like in there just like a
slow motion or orgy everyone's just
naked dancing or what and apparently
that scene was much longer in the yeah I
think I got a lot of that out and in the
back of the love shop there's a there
was a secret door that led to kind of a
more clandestine area with a bunch of
people with these weird steam steam
Spears I guess you could say it was like
a spear with a crystal on the end of it
that looked like a penis pump on the end
I shot some kind of hot steam out of it
but Lovins got it got his a butane
lighter gun and he holds them off at bay
well here's here's something that
interested me about this okay so at this
point Logan is still working for the
Dome City right because you're soon as
they get into the clandestine area with
all Jessica's friends he surreptitiously
alerts all the other Sandman yeah he had
like a little radio type device yeah but
not he's like right hey here they are
yeah he thought he thought he had found
sanctuary I'm thinking that's maybe what
the implication was oh oh here's
sanctuary with all these seditious
people in one place right so he pressed
a button and all the salmon show up they
kill all those people
yeah they nailed all Jessica's friends
yeah lol Jessica's friends and he and
Jessica run to the back and Jessica says
take the ark is beyond Sakhi yeah to get
out yeah right and she drops hers
partying is a watermelon girl he
invented some water but Logan still has
his and he opens the door they go
through now Francis the other fellow
yeah the other yeah man he sees all this
happening and he grabs the walk out of
the water uses it as a key to also open
the door and where it leads to is a big
like a subterranean looks like a factory
yeah it's like the bowels of the doll of
the city and how because it's kind of
weird they go up they don't go down they
go up yeah because they fall into well
don't they fall in there's like all this
water and then they go into an elevator
and then they go up yeah not really sure
how are infusing where this is
happening because this is not an
underground society it's just in a dome
yeah they go up and it gets cold I don't
really understand well why should they
do that the bowels of the city it kind
of looks like a fish hatchery yeah it's
a big fish fish I mean there's big tanks
and there are still fish in there yeah
it looks like yeah but then some of the
tanks look like they're empty and it was
unused right I don't know who's feeding
this fish and Logan just says you know
this is where the city's food supply
used to be produced they used to breed
animals for food and Jeff liked those so
they run they go up and it gets cold
it's frozen and this is the weirdest
part of the airport and they go into
this frozen ice cave and there's big ice
sculptures of wall of a walrus and a
bunch of penguins and birds and this big
kind of a humanoid robot rolls out it's
got arms and it's got arms and it has a
head but but it doesn't have legs its
body just stands up and it's it's got
rollers yeah and it's made out of mirror
and this cool little Porsche a nice cool
little guy comes down in box yeah you
got his voice yeah I'm gonna put that a
display that's what you need okay
welcome human I am ready for this
Langton he greens and protein from the
steam press as harvest
overwhelming am i not fish and plankton
from the sea I love that yeah yeah I
love that guy's voice he did a lot of
voiceover work late he'd been in a
shit-ton a movie student's name is Ross
Gurley Brown he's dead no unfortunately
but if you look at his Wikipedia page he
was in a [ __ ] ton of movies and he did a
[ __ ] ton of voice work an eejit and even
wrote plays and things like that - he's
a he was a golden yeah and he's a real
standout character in the movie
now some people are calling him a robot
but he clearly says that he is a fusion
of man and machine like a cyborg more
than the two of abouit so he's a cyborg
yeah and he's been down there by himself
alone and he is definitely insane now in
a deleted scene he makes a deal with
them that he will show them where the
Rutter's went if they'll if they allow
themselves to pose for a sculpture and
he's real talented and he sculpts them
quickly out of ice out of ice
naked of quarter and then he takes him
to the back I guess it's a back doesn't
really yeah it's just like a huge big
ice cave this is actually cool this is
actually this part when I saw this is a
kid it kind of scared me yeah she taken
to another area of the cave and there's
a bunch of frozen people there and he
says you know the food stopped coming
from a TV from the sea so they came but
then these people started coming my job
I thought I'd freeze it - yeah he's
right so he bears down on him but Logan
blows him up with his butane lighter
like you do right so apartment boxes box
that box yeah so he's finished and they
keep going in the end up leaving the ice
yeah they get out and they get out of
the dome I don't get outside and they
see the Sun for the first time they've
never seen it everywhere in a sonic so
I'm pretty sure they lifted that from
thx 1138 yeah when thick's finally gets
out of it how much we might do a review
every I do that's a good one actually
write that down oh good
write that matter to you okay so they
get outside and they've never been
outside before and they're kind of
wandering around and it's funny because
this part is actually pretty funny to me
because Jessica is like immediately
searched whining about how much outside
sucks yeah that's cool where's the food
yeah because you know she didn't know
and she's like lived her whole entire
life and they walk around
and obviously this is the ruins of
Washington DC the Capitol building you
see the Lincoln Memorial
now they don't know what this is or why
it's there Lincoln it or who's Lincoln
is me I don't like it twice yeah a show
is a statue and then later on in the
Library of Congress they thought they'd
find a portrait portrait of it yeah and
there's an old guy living in there with
a bunch of cats yeah in the Senate in
the Senate chamber an innocent
yeah they eventually find the Senate
chamber and they find an old man who's
played by Peter Ustinov he's never named
he's just called old man yeah and he
lives in there with a bunch of cats and
he's actually a really good character
like he's obviously a little addled but
like in a cool like nice grandpa way not
like in a crazy lunatic kind of way so
he lived with all these cats and they've
also knit they've never seen an old
person before so they're like what's the
matter with you why is your hair gray
what what are all these cuts in your
face she said do they hurt and stuff
like that he's like well the clock okay
whatever and they'd never seen cats
before either and the cats have three
names that you have Thursday that's like
a TSL yeah he was recording from TS
Eliot's a book of practical cats but
yeah so there's old guys there and and
he says that now his parents were
runners right yeah you
well you're led to believe that yeah I
think it's implied that his parents were
brothers so the box didn't get all the
runners and I actually did get out now
they're city computer said there were
less eleven hundred a thousand one
thousand 56,000 86 or 1156 sembly when
Rahner is unaccounted for
well what box shows the frozen people
the box shows that's probably about 60
people yeah so he didn't get them all
yeah so they did get out
I figured if Logan and Jessica got out
then some of the other people must have
got our two I would think and how fast
could box rolls right yeah that's what I
mean it's like I'm you know obviously
you didn't get killed before Nelson Oh
what else shot him or anything like that
but it's like Gendron from some people
could just sneak through or maybe he
didn't hear them or something like that
but yeah so the old man is implied that
the old man's parents were maybe runners
and they did get married and they did
raise him yeah I died he buried them
yeah which Logan and Jessica think is
very weird because that's not like but
they're kind of really fascinated by
that feel like maybe that's the way it's
supposed to be you know now Francis
caught up with in yeah attacked
during the Senate chamber and then there
was a big fight that makes a wrong man
kill him and Logan ends up killing it
with a flagpole right anybody has a
black hole or something like that and he
dies actually the moment he dies he sees
Logan's hand and he sees that Logan's
crystal is clear now yeah like it
doesn't work anymore run and he's like
what and then he dies yeah you know I
mean so I think that was kind of a
significant moment just again Logan at
first promise the old man because he's
like well all I want is you know someone
to bury me when I die like I said like I
buried my parents and then Jessica says
that they will but then Logan says no we
have to go back because we have to tell
all the people in the Dome City that
that you can livi that you can live
beyond 30 and that yeah and and it's
implied to that the world outside is now
ready to be repopulated yeah because you
know all the plants have grown back and
it looks totally fine
yeah so I get it yeah so I guess it's
gotten past the point with whatever
nuclear annihilation messed up the whole
environment if it ever did could be that
they were just that the society just
reengineered to just how he'll hold
people captive possible yeah it could be
I mean I I thought because I think at
the beginning like the opening crawl I
think it said that there was a war that
wiped everything out but you know I mean
I did recovered whatever it is yeah so
obviously it looks like it's recovered
then so Logan says no we have to go back
and then the old man says we'll no you
said you were going to stay and bury me
and all this other stuff so they said
why don't you come back with us and I
can show all the people in the city you
know yeah okay he's like okay what add
the people I'll see all the young people
yes yeah he's like I love his character
just you just like so accommodating he's
like okay so so they actually they bury
Francis and have a funeral for him and
then they go back to the city now Logan
and Jessica have to go back and this
really like convoluted weather to go
underwater and all this other stuff so
they leave the old guy kind of outside
and they said okay now we're going to
bring everybody to you because obviously
you can't swim through this big thing
and all the rise so he goes in now he
gets caught this is kind of funny yeah
it's his frigate he runs in and they're
half they're all going to carousel yeah
so everybody in town is like in the
middle of the mall so he's running
through the mall and he's yelling down
out I'm through like off of one of the
little balcony things you don't have to
die
you don't gotta say it like
I don't have to die and the arrest is
asked because yeah it's funny because
everybody like in the crowd you know my
guess is he gets arrested yeah and then
you have another good scene where they
take him back to the to the city's main
computer so he's back in the Death Star
and they got it strapped to this chair
and this is like one of the highlights
of the movies because for the first time
I'm like showing laser and that laser
what they called a hologram hologram was
the first use of how of real holograms
on film you guys yeah fun fact
so they got him strapped to this chair
the computers read in his mind and
they're asking the computers asking
where sanctuary is you know and the
Holograms of his head or spinning and
there any I can gold boxes on you
decided to tend to go there is no
sanctuary old man ruins and all kind of
[ __ ] is pretty cool yeah I like that
creeps me out there's a kid that is box
creeped me out when I was little that
ended somehow he gets into this big mind
wrestling match with the main computer
and the main computer blows up it's like
a contradiction because you he can the
computer can read
Logan's mind so you knows that Logan is
telling the truth but it's like the
computers programming says there is a
sanctuary that's where the runners are
going bro so those two things contradict
each other and just like in Star Trek
when you know Kirk trying to do the
little logical impossibility and the
computer is like yeah yeah kind of like
Nomad yes like no exactly exactly like
that there was a lot of their lives
oh yeah movies but so basically so the
computer blows up all the people are
relieved all the people are released
from the dome and they all go outside
and see the old man and they're always
like whoa and they're just like blown
away how cool this is
and that's pretty much the moment yeah
so the implication being that since the
environment is now back to normal and
since all these people so they've been
it's almost kind of like a reverse
well it's not like reverse but it's
almost kind of like they were in Eden
and then they were kind of carried that
out of these because it's going to be
for them because they don't know
anything like a bunch of dummies now
here's where it differs for the book and
in a way like some of the books from
some of the ideas from the book I like
better and some of the ideas from the
movie I like better in the book like I
said it was almost like a worldwide
thing it wasn't just a dome city but in
the book that people were not dummies
like they knew what the Sun was they
knew about history they said in a matter
of fact in the book they had Androids
like reenacting Civil War battles and
things like that so people knew who Abe
Lincoln was and they knew what had
happened they knew about the war and
stuff like that in the movie it's
implied that I guess the central
computer finds it more pertinent not to
give them any information they didn't
know anything that's to keep them dumb
and happy you know like yeah drugs
casual sex whatever just shut up and
leave us alone
they were very naive yes they didn't
know it and like I said as soon as Logan
and Jessica left the Dome City they saw
the Sun and they're like what the [ __ ]
is that like they didn't know what it
was they didn't know what outside was
nothing and remember you know when Logan
five first meets Jessica Jessica is
asking all these important questions
about life and he said why do you asking
me why do you think about this you know
so yeah so like it don't look like it
didn't occurred about yeah their culture
was very superficial yeah it was like
outside yeah it like everything was like
very youth obsessed like I said plastic
surgery was very easy people would go
get it done all the time it was just
like with lasers they'd take your face
off and give me a new one and you had a
big deal yeah no need if they paid for
it no I don't think they paid for any of
it the resume I don't think they paid
for anything - really kind of a whole
point of the movie and it and it kind of
came out like the book came out of 1967
and then the movie came out in 1976 but
I think the whole idea for the book kind
of came out of the whole youth obsessed
you know the counterculture of the Sufis
and don't trust anyone over Authority
and stuff like that and but it was kind
of showing you know free love and drugs
and stuff but it was kind of showing the
dark side of that yeah they would seem
like that's not utopia right that you
may think it is but it had a dark side
just like a utopia isn't true yeah and I
think that was also kind of like and I
don't know if I've seen anybody talk
about this really but there was almost
kind of like a religious metaphor
because now in the book sanctuary was a
real place there was a place called
sanctuary in the movie there wasn't it
was just kind of it was a Miss just like
renewal at carousel and stuff like that
so
almost kind of like they were telling
these people you know fictions that
would make them feel better yeah and you
know to keep them from questioning
anything yeah but you know the fact that
even though they seem to be like
genetically engineering these people
obviously well you know as we know now
that's not an exact science anyway
because you're never going to get
anybody that's like perfectly docile and
perfectly happy to be dumb you're always
going to get like a small percentage of
like [ __ ] this alright you know with so
so they didn't crack down and the
presence of the Cubs in the Cathedral
shows that they were not entirely in
control of the population because
remember still some of these kids that
took off feral kids yeah like feral kids
that wanted to live in the ghettos and
didn't want it a part of it and there
were still like at least a thousand
people that had taken off because they
didn't want any part of this [ __ ] it's
definitely kind of it's definitely a
kind of thing where they're trying to
recreate eating yeah alright it's a kind
of a futuristic eating where you you
don't have to till the soil you don't
have to work you just have fun have
pleasure and you die early yeah but it's
a lie
yes that's what that's what that's the
meaning of the other movie if you ask me
yeah I think it is yet it is a lie that
it's superficial that you know you
actually have to till the soil you have
to live a long life it's not necessarily
good yeah I and there's no renewal yeah
but it's true yeah you know so you know
you just kind of have to take comfort
from that as well yeah it's not saying I
don't think it's saying oh you know life
out that is back because it obviously
showed I mean the old man was he was a
little bit addled but he was he seemed
happy with all your ass and stuff like
that yeah you know I can't piss but it's
all right he seemed to be having it all
right time and yeah he really didn't
seem to be having any trouble eating
everything like that so I guess yet agar
I would say it was definitely anti you
utopia yeah well most of those types of
movies are because I think that's the
thing I think a lot of the movies that
came out around that time that people
were like you know you know that we can
make a perfect utopia or simple like
that and I think everybody kind of knows
deep down that that's not ever going to
happen and it's if I go just from memory
there weren't any black people in the
city other than the actor who played
bucks but you couldn't see them so which
that matches up with 1800s and early
1900s
steps of utopia that everyone is to say
everyone's the same yeah and everyone is
the same
yeah that there's no diversity there's
only unity so it's one people one race
one religion one language because
there's no conflict yeah there's no
difference yeah because in any case
where you're going to get a couple
people are like hey I don't like the way
this go under so that's that then you're
going to have her hey I'm different from
you there was no difference they were
all the same they're all the same here
all this any and they were all young
yeah
it's that's the thing yeah you know so I
mean after Star Wars came out in 1977
you know obviously people kind of forgot
about Logan's Run for wildly with it I
saw it on TV
I either saw it on TV like on a cable
channel or I saw it on a page channel
like Cinemax or something like that I
think they replayed a lot of those kind
of 70s because I saw Soylent Green and
[ __ ] like that but you know if you like
that idea behind Soylent Green or brave
new world this takes a lot of ideas from
brave new world
yeah the different colors the agents and
thx 1138 which we actually might do a
review a check once is similar yeah it's
very similar darker though yeah
though but here's nothing the Logan's
Run is not a light-hearted adventure no
not really it's so kind of a downer in a
certain way although it is pretty yeah
it's kind of pretty to look at very
shiny thx is the same story in a certain
way except it's really oppressive yeah
slow moving and very heavy
THX's yeah I mean those people had
nothing yeah basically that was just
about man mankind living down into
subterranean hole force to take drugs
and to be into worship of God of
Commerce
yeah it's a good that's what which like
I said it was similar idea to this but
this was done like anybody aware I fix
oh yeah that was yeah that was that was
so that was more like 1984 well I 90 day
board so um this one was it encouraged I
don't think it made people take drugs or
made people have casual sex but they
just like to encourage that that was
like looters nothing else to do there
was nothing else to do so that's just
kind of what everyone did and no one
discouraged it that was just the way it
was yeah when I first when I really
first started to think about this I
thought that maybe the city and Logan's
Run itself was more like a lifeboat
alright but I don't feel like that's
probably what it is that
an apocalypse happens the survivors go
into this very protective dome where
they can just get lost in hedonistic
pleasure but they die at 30 yeah all
right but it doesn't matter because more
of them are made yeah
and they're not really doing anything
anyway but it's easier for the city
computer to take care of them if they're
young and healthy yeah when they get old
now you have to start worried about
convalescence and medical problems right
so they're killing them in their prime
and then I thought the idea was is that
when the environment gets better the
dome is unlocked so everyone can
everyone can go out Andrea populate the
earth yeah that's kind of what I thought
that's what I thought was happening kind
of with the the final interrogation yet
I mean Logan where the computer is
finding out that you know ruins you know
the old man there is no sanctuary I
thought that maybe the computer had
realized that that the environment had
recovered so because there was someone
living out there yeah so destroyed
destroyed the computer and unlock yeah
maybe maybe it wasn't even so I mean it
was implied in the movie that it was the
contradiction that made the computer
blow up but like you said maybe it was
the fact of him breeding his thoughts
and seeing that the outside looked like
and that there was someone living out
there there's like oh well it's okay now
yes so now I can destroy myself
ya ever know happen to have the city
right let him go out and repopulate the
earth I thought that maybe that's what
had happened but knowing more about the
book and and some of the deleted scenes
no I don't think that that's what it was
anyone I mean possibly maybe the guy who
directed the movie said well that's you
know that's a plausibility that this is
just a like a like a white boat or an
ark yeah but I don't think that was the
original intent maybe not all those like
I said there were they were very subtle
but there were kind of a lot of
religious metaphors in there like you
said an ark that was that's a very good
kind of a religious metaphor yeah I said
that would be now out living there now
we're unleashing of Eden yeah so you
know the other way the multiplier
whatever work the multiply which maybe
is maybe it's what it applies I think
that's what they turned the story into
yeah I don't think that's originally you
know based on the book that's not was it
the original intent yeah but like I said
the movie made a lot of changes
so you know maybe the original intent of
the book wasn't the same as the movie I
don't know they're - they're kind of two
different it's just an arc they don't
have to grow old they don't have to
learn anything and they don't have to do
all this it's better if you just keep
them dumb and you're keeping kind of
like a human race in suspended animation
this yes stasis you don't want them to
get too old because then they start
figuring out too much and they might
destroy the city right you know which
could end those long as you keep them
young and dumb and you know keep it on
drugs and yeah and then you and just
keep recycling them until the
environments good and then you and then
you let them out and when they're all
still young enough to reproduce we have
babies and stuff like that right so you
know you figured well they'll figure it
out well that's what I thought it that's
right I'll figure it out when they get
yeah definitely but you know maybe they
will will be but uh [ __ ] we went on
almost an hour about Logan's rise it was
long I dunno if you get a chance go
check out Louise right yeah and there's
like a lot of I mean I think the movie
is kind of spurred a lot of discussion
like you know what I mean it has a cult
following it really does you can watch
it on YouTube
I think it's about $2.99 yeah you can
watch another pei-pei youtube that's how
we got this thing has been Logan's Run a
remake or a sequel has been in
development hell for 20 years yeah
Logan's Run may reappear but I doubt it
yeah I mean if it's been like in
suspended animation for that long I
don't know but you know it might it
might it actually might be good it was
updated but I don't know I don't have
much face that they won't mess it up
yeah oh [ __ ] it and the thing about
Logan's Run that's cool yes it looks
very dated I mean it looks very 70s
that's kind of part of its charm I think
yeah because it's very it has like a
really distinctive look to it like you
know the way the modern mall is very
much that sterile yeah look at a sterile
mall and I liked all the colors like
it's very brightly colored it's not like
one of those dystopian movies where
everything's brown and gray and you know
very very colorful looks like a
playground yeah inside yeah so I liked
that about it because it's cut it was
kind of unusual in that genre it's it
kind of get kind of fits in with my
concept of it the city is just an arc
yeah to keep them happy and reproducing
and you can just recycle them you're
eliminating all conflicts so that way
the city is not or the arc is not
destroyed
eternal conflict right so you're just
kind of held in stasis yeah okay so that
was our discussion about Logan's Run we
went on kind of longer than yeah was it
so that we did about other ones oh well
that's okay once we start talking but uh
okay hope you guys enjoy Me's movie
reviews we will have more to come we
have a huge long list so you know if you
have any recommendations then let us
know we will try to get to eventually
but like I said we have probably a
couple hundred movies that they guy that
prioritize them to see what's you know
what would be what would be a good one
to do next yeah some of these were the
good ones you got to save until we
really get doing retrospectives down to
a science
yeah sure because I have a feeling we'll
get better and better at this as we go
yeah we probably will okay so I guess
we'll wrap this up please remember to go
support us on patreon I'll put a link in
the description and it was there
anything else you would like to say
about Logan's Run slow-moving or GC
overwhelming am i fish frags is from the
sea she agrees I love that guide step
outside even though I still have no idea
what the [ __ ] that whole sequence of the
movie is supposed to represent but it's
just even when I was seeing it when I
was a kid I was like that was random
what the hell it may be an analogy
between with the Garden of Eden the
Garden of Eden was being guarded by a
flaming sword an angel may be there you
know instead of a flaming sorts of
frozen sword yeah like a Guardians
frozen garbage okay that make sense
thank you you just explain that part
yeah okay so see you guys later bye